I was walking in New York City with Mr
Adams uh Adam sacks remember and we were
walking together and you saw
a post on like dumois seconds afterwards
you want to lean in and tell this we
were walking together we were in New
York City doing some had some meeting or
something and then we're walking up uh
right past Rockefeller Center yeah and
then uh someone said someone texted me a
like an Instagram post from DuBois that
was like uh a picture of me and you
together and it was like Conan and his
intern walking through
oh
you're an Adam yeah Adam Conan with his
13 year old nephew exactly were you
telling him go get us some Cokes sure
yeah